un bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue pour ce retour critique sur le
paléo news numéro 15 où nous vous
annoncions la de la publication d'un
article qui disait que les raptor ne
chassait pas en meute et je trouve que
ça que ce que ce serait intéressant en
fait de faire un retour critique là
dessus pour bien vous montrer en fait
d'où sort l'idée que les raptor ne
chassait pas en meute et pour ça faut
revenir à l'idée de base qui est
pourquoi est ce qu'on dit que les
rapports chassent en meute
parce que cette idée évidemment elle ne
sort pas de nulle part et je pense que
c'est intéressant de faire une petite
vidéo pour revenir à la source même de
cette idée de voir son cheminement de
voir comment elle a été reçue par les
paléontologues de voir quelles sont les
preuves
finalement derrière ce comportement de
chasse en meute que tout le monde a
l'air d'accepter et pourquoi du coup la
découvre pourquoi finalement l' annonce
que finalement les raptor ne chassez pas
en meute devrait être acceptée bien plus
que bien plus que la chasse en meute qui
elle est complètement acceptée par la
plupart des gens il faut savoir que la
chasse en meute c'est quand même une
idée qui a à peu près 50 ans qui a été
largement accepté largement diffusée par
les médias largement diffusée dans l'est
dans les livres notamment dans les
livres pour enfants donc c'est une idée
qui s'imprime dans notre tête très tôt
dans notre vie de paléo geek
donc on est en droit de se demander
quelles sont les preuves derrière ça est
ce que le est-ce que la popularité de
cette idée reflète vraiment la force des
preuves qui sont derrière et du coup est
ce que il faut accepter que les raptor
ne chassait pas en meute
oui ou non donc on va se faire une
petite vidéo là dessus et pour ça est-ce
que ce qu'il ya d'intéressant aussi avec
ça justement c'est que ça va permettre
de soulever une idée qui est extrêmement
importante dans quand on parle
d'interprétation du registre fossile et
cette idée c'est la différence entre une
biocénose une thanatos et noz et une
taffe hausse et n'osent alors une
biocénose déjà qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une scène de vie voilà quand vous
regardez un animal quand vous regardez
un écosystème
vous regardez un écureuil en train de
manger un gland c'est une biocénose donc
vous voyez l'écureuil manger un gland et
vous pouvez en faire la différence
vous pouvez faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable que les écureuils mange des
glands c'est le comportement de cet
écureuil reflète le comportement de
l'espèce donc vous interpréter une
biocénose pour en tirer une conclusion
plus grande que le simple individu que
vous êtes en train d'observer ça c'est
l'interprétation d'une biocénose parlons
maintenant de l'interprétation des
thanatos et n'ose donc une thanatos et
n'osent c'est une scène de mort thanatos
thanos la mort au moins la moitié
claquement de doigts tout ça non
thanatos et n'osent mais c'est un moyen
mnémotechnique si vous voulez voilà
retenez thanos thanatos enos
voilà c'est ce sera le nouveau méchant
dans marvel thanatos et n'osent c'est
une scène de mort donc c'est l'animal
tel qu'il est mort voyez ce poisson
alors ce poisson ne s'est pas étouffer
les poissons ne s'étouffe pas puisqu'ils
ne l'ont pas de poumons
par contre ce poisson il a avalé une
proie plus grosse que sa bouche il est
resté coincé et il est probablement mort
de faim après donc et il est le voit la
mort enfin fossilisés tel qu'il est mort
c'est à dire avec son poisson dans la
tronche comme un crétin ça c'est une
thanatos et noz et on interprète cette
thanatos et n'osent comme étant bon ce
poisson se nourrit normalement de ce
type d'animal mais là ça a merdé
mais par contre ce qui est le problème
avec les thanatos et n'osent c'est qu'on
ne regarde pas un animal vivant on
regarde un animal mort on regarde la
façon dont cet animal est mort donc dans
cette can atos et n'osent on pourrait
tout aussi bien interpréter que ce
poisson ne mange pas habituellement ce
genre de petit poisson là puisqu'en fait
quand ils le mangent ils meurent voyez
où je veux en venir c'est à dire qu'on
peut interpréter cette thanatos et
n'osent de deux façons non seulement de
deux façons différentes mais de deux
façons totalement opposé à savoir que
d'une on peut interpréter cette thanatos
et n'osent comme ce poisson mange
habituellement celui là mais ce coup ci
ça a merdé ou deux
ce poisson ne mange pas habituellement
celui là et c'est pour ça qu'il est mort
les deux conclusions sont totalement
opposés voyez et on peut même partir sur
une troisième interprétation qui est ce
poisson est mort d'une condition
totalement qu'il est mort d'une
troisième cause totalement inconnu est
différente pendant qu'il mangeait ce
poisson c'est une troisième
interprétation donc voilà le problème de
la tasse d'atos et n'osent c'est qu'on
interprète une scène de morts et pas une
scène de vie donc on n'a pas accès
directement à l'information et ça
devient encore plus un problème quand on
parle de ta fausse et n'osent alors là
une taffe au semnoz c'est le pire truc a
interprété au monde parce qu'une tafo
ses noces hainaut seulement une scène de
mort mais une scène de mort qui qui a
bougé qui n'est pas en place ici par
exemple alors vous avez un morceau
d'ambré vous avez des insectes mais
surtout vous avez une ammonite vous avez
une ammonite dans un morceau d'ambré
donc si vous interpréter cette info ses
noces comme une biocénose les ammonites
grimpe aux arbres à c'est la conclusion
c'est la conclusion il en a pas d'autre
donc et et non évidemment les ammonites
sont des animaux éminemment aquatique du
mois autour autant qu'on sache donc non
les ammonites de crabes pas aux arbres
mais vous êtes juste en train de mal
interpréter une hta fossé noz c'est à
dire un animal qui est mort dans l'eau a
été rejetée sur une plage donc qui est
qui et qui a commencé à son processus de
fossilisation loin de l'endroit où il
est mort ce que déjà être rejetée sur la
plage pour la bonite c'est déjà ne plus
être à l'endroit où elle est morte
donc elle a été rejetée sur la plage
bon allez je vous accorde peut-être
qu'elle a été jeté sur la plage et
qu'elle est morte après mais en tout cas
ensuite à l'infini dans le morceau
dambre delambre lui a coulé de fin de la
sève d'arbres lui a coulé dessus et 7
serbe sef d'arbres s'est transformé en
en ambre résultant du fossile mais là la
mauny tu n'es pas morte dans son milieu
de vie
elle est morte dans un milieu de mort
voilà dans un milieu où elle ne peut pas
vivant
donc donc ce qu'on interprète là c'est
clairement la façon dont la monitrice et
juste fossilisés pas du tout la façon
dont l'âme ni tu as vécu et pas non plus
la façon dont elle est morte juste la
façon dont elle sait fossilisés et même
en partant du principe que la monuc
était encore plus ou moins vivante quand
elle était sur la plage quand lambres
lui est tombé dessus
elle était déjà techniquement foutu donc
commencez pas à chercher la petite bête
là je vous vois je vous vois chercher la
petite bête dans les commentaires c'est
pas bien donc voilà
thanatos et n'osent scène de morte a
faussé nos scènes de fossilisation enfin
scène de dépôt et rien d'autre c'est
juste le dépôt que vous regardez c'est
même pas la scène de la mort donc
maintenant on va faire un petit essai
pour voir si vous avez bien suivi
quand on dit quand on dit que ça c'est
l'humérus de lucie quand on dit que la
tête de l'humérus de l'uci s'est
enfoncée quand elle est tombée d'un
arbre et que du coup elle s'est
rattrapée sur le bras et que son épaule
a enfoncé la tête de son humérus dans
son bras processus éminemment douloureux
quand on dit que parce que cette tête du
mary s'est enfoncé dans leur intérieur
du bras comme ça ça veut dire qu'elle
est tombée d'un arbre et que donc elle
vivait dans les arbres question c'est
quoi le problème dans ce raisonnement
mal le problème c'est qu'elle est morte
en tombant de l'arbre dans cette
interprétation donc ça veut dire
qu'elles étaient extrêmement mauvaises à
vivre dans les arbres ou alors ça veut
dire qu'elle vivait habituellement dans
les arbres mais que pour une fois elle a
merdé et que ça lui a été fatale à et ça
c'est seulement si on admet donc déjà on
a le fameux problème des deux
interprétations diamétralement opposées
dans le cas d'une thanatos et n'osent
mais en plus le problème c'est que l'uci
c'est tout à fait discutable est-ce que
c'était une taffe hausser nos zones
thanatos et n'osent parce que si vous
avez vu ma vidéo une vertèbre de
babouins dans le squelette de lucy
vous savez que l'uci a l'a pas été
elle n'a pas été trouvée comme ça
magnifiquement en articulation comme ce
joli poisson 1
elle a été trouvée un peu répandu tout
partout il y avait que quelques
vertèbres en articulation alors les
scientifiques qui l'on trouvait à
l'époque donc johansson a fait
l'hypothèse que l'uci enfin que le
squelette était articulé parce qu'ils
ont trouvé quelques vertèbres articulé
mai et que donc c'était une taffe hausse
et n'osent mais depuis on a trouvé qu'il
y avait une vertèbre de babouins dans le
tas ce qui suggère qu'en fait on est
peut-être face à une tape fossé noz et
alors là tout l'interprétation de
l'arbre la chute le bras qui s'enfonce
tout ça ça tombe par terre parce que si
ça se trouve dans le cas d'une hta fossé
noz là ça ça a pu arriver après la
fossilisation voyez donc faut faire
attention et maintenant petit piège le
l'ichtyose or en train d'accoucher les
fameuses ichthyosaures en train
d'accoucher de hold madden est ce que
déjà bon taf au sénat ou thanatos et
n'osent là tout le squelette est
articulé bien en place on peut
raisonnablement dire tu un fossé noz on
est face à une scène de mort donc on est
face à un ichthyosaures qui est mort en
donnant la vie
maintenant est ce que c'est parce que
les ichthyosaures le faisait
habituellement un peu comme les dauphins
mais que cette fois ça a merdé
ou bien est ce que est ce que c'est un
dinosaure qui tentait un truc nouveau et
qui est mort parce qu'il n'était pas du
tout faits pour ça les ichthyosaures ah
ben dis comme ça enfin dit comme ça
l'idée que les ichthyosaures donné
naissance à des petits vivent et
peut-être tellement imprimé dans votre
cerveau que vous à vous n'avez pas
vraiment envie de croire quand je vous
dis que éventuellement c'était peut-être
un ichtyosaure qui tentait un truc
nouveau mais il faut bien l'admettre que
les l'hypothèse que les ichtyosaures que
cette ichthyosaures est mort en donnant
la vie de cette façon parce que il
n'avait pas l'habitude de donner la vie
de cette façon et que du coup ça a
provoqué sa mort elle n'est pas
complètement stupide donc évidemment je
ne remets pas en question le fait que
les ichthyosaures donné naissance de
cette façon on a
on a quand même suffisamment de bonnes
raisons de croire que cette thanatos et
n'osent reflète une biocénose qui a mal
tourné mais n'empêche que voilà et les
bonnes raisons c'est que justement les
dauphins moderne donne naissance les
petits avec l'accueil en premier
exactement comme cette scène là donc
c'est exactement ce qu'on s'attendrait à
voir d'un animal qui ne peut plus
revenir sur terre pour pondre des oeufs
parce qu'il a publiée voilà il ya plus
de debra mais il a pu de pied et puis le
corps le corps est verticalement allongé
donc s'il avait essayé de se traîner sur
le sol c'est comme une baleine il aurait
fini par s'étouffer donc
donc on est d'accord que non on est bien
d'accord que je ne remets pas en
question l'hypothèse que les
ichthyosaures ne pondent ehpad off et
donner naissance à des petits
directement dans l'eau c'est ce qu'on
s'attend à voir pour un animal de cette
façon et on en aurait fait cette
hypothèse même sans avoir découvert ce
fossile là mais faut quand même bien
garder ça à l'esprit oui et que même des
cas qu'on considère comme coulant de
source sont pas forcément interprétable
en terme de deux biocénose ce qui nous
conduit du cou à l'idée bien ancrée à la
doctrine donc j'utilise leur
j'utiliserai le mot doctrine enfin
j'essaierai d'utiliser le mot doctrine
parce que c est ce qu un des auteurs
qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui
enfin c'est la façon dont un des auteurs
combats dont on va parler aujourd'hui à
parler du l'hypothèse de raptor qui
chassent en meute ils appellent ça la
doctrine des raptors qui chassent en
meute tellement cette idée est imprimé
dans le l'inconscient collectif donc
justement ça nous amène à la doctrine
des raptor qui chassent en meute et
cette doctrine elle vient alors elle
vient de john ostrom à la base donc
jeunes ostrom qui seul homme qui a
découvert des molécules sein qui a nommé
dénommé cuche dans les années 60 quand
ils découvrent des nonick us et qu'il
publie pour la première fois fin des
années 60 il me semble il trouve des t
notes aux orres associés à des données
cus donc ténontosaure c1 ornitho pod
jordi guano dont idées et des mots ni qc
évidemment c'est un raptor et ils les
trouvent ensemble plein de démonique us
avec un ténontosaure donc il fait à
l'époque il jette l'idée en l'air on va
dire que des nonick us chasser en meute
parce qu'on trouve plein de t notes aux
orres avec dédé nonick us maintenant
vous savez même empruntant du principe
que c'est une taffe au semnoz mais on va
en discuter
même en partant du principe qu'il avait
à faire une taffe hausse et n'ose vous
savez que trouver des fossiles de
détonique us mort à côté d'un thé noto
or more basse aveux au ça veut tout
aussi ça peut tout aussi bien vouloir
dire que c'était l'unique us il était
nul quand ils chasser en groupe et qui
sont morts en chassant comme des manches
à son ensemble parce qu'ils savaient pas
le faire donc voilà attention à
l'interprétation d'état fossé n'ose donc
ils ont refait un article un peu plus
tard enfin longtemps plus tard en 1995
est donc là l'article que je vais vous
montrer la sauce cet article là c'est
vraiment le l'argument massue de tous
les gens qui défendent la théorie des dd
nonick us chasseurs en meute c'est 1900d
maxwell et ostrom 1995 c'est la pierre
angulaire du truc et donc on va on va
voir un petit peu ce que ça
ce que ça donne donc ils ont étudié deux
sites le site où ils ont découvert des
nonick us pour la première fois qui est
celui là est un autre site où ils ont
découvert un assemblage de dénis qc de
ténontosaure donc il ya plein de sites
où on a découvert des des données qu cdt
l'honteuse en finale deux grands sites
justement mais il ya plein d'endroits et
parce où on trouve des associations
entre des raptor en général et des
ornithologues ou des mêmes des indes
rose or en général mais là ils ont quand
même choisi de prendre les plus probants
donc déjà c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
se dire en premier c'est que ça c'est
des trucs les plus probants et on va
commencer déjà par le site original donc
il me semble que c'est celui-là le site
original ou d'ennemis cus a été trouvé
le site web qui m 64 75 dans le montana
donc ici ce qu'on a c'est un squelette
d'allosaure marqué en noir notamment la
queue ici et quelques fragments biens
dispersés et on a 1 2 au moins trois
squelettes de démo ni cus donc donc on
reconnaît par la queue encore une
articulation et encore des fragments en
blanc biens dispersés et aussi des
fragments rayé des morceaux de crâne
rayé ici
donc ça c'est l'endroit original ou des
no need u ça a été découvert donc est ce
que c'est une tâche fossé nosu une
thanatos haineuse là on a tous les os
qui sont dispersés un peu partout
donc si c'est une si c'est pas une offre
au cndd aux basses et une base à 2 c au
moins une thanatos haineuse qui a
salement prix elle a pris cher si si les
squelettes était d'abord articulé mais
qu'après ça a été désarticulé par des
processus alors post mortem c'est-à-dire
d'autres animaux qui sont venues
disperser les charognes d'autres
carnivores qui sont venues disperser des
sharon ou géologiques mais là je vois
pas trop comment un processus biologique
pourrait si à la limite une rivière qui
passe dessus une rivière en crue qu'ils
passent dessus qui dispersent tous les
os après ça pourrait ça pourrait marcher
donc voilà c'est faut admettre que si
c'est une thanatos et n'osent est là il
ya eu du mouvement dedans déjà d'une
part donc elle est dure à interpréter en
termes de teint de thanatos et noz et il
est aussi probable du coût que ce soit
une taffe au semnoz c'est à dire il est
plus fort probable que ces squelettes
n'est probablement rien à voir les uns
avec les autres mais qu'ils ont été
accumulées par un processus en commun
par exemple une rivière en crue qui
emmène des cadavres jusque dans un lac
et les squelettes tous les corps vont
aller se déposer spontanément dans le
point le plus profond du lac yvon
sédimenter au plus profond du lac et du
coup ça va faire un assemblage de
squelettes et hasard malencontreux
il y avait des dénommés qcd ténontosaure
dans le tas et donc ils se retrouvent
tous ensemble
donc ça c'est aussi quelque chose si
selon qu'on interprète sac et déjà comme
une thanatos enzo comme une terre fossé
noces ça change complètement
l'interprétation du site et maintenant
même si on admet qu'on est face à une
thanatos et n'ose donc à une scène de
mort eh ben c'est pas encore dit que les
dés nonick us étaient là pour chasser le
ténontosaure puisque encore une fois
cédé nonick us sont morts dans le
processus
donc ils ont pu tout aussi bien de
mourir parce qu'ils étaient très mauvais
à ce jeu là ou peut-être qu'il ne
chassait pas en meute c'est aussi
possible que 3d nonick us se soient
retrouvées à chasser le même t notes aux
ors et qui se sont entretués sur la
voilà avant ou après avoir blessé à mort
le ténontosaure d'ailleurs peut-être
qu'il y avait même un quatrième larron
dans l'histoire genre un tyrannosaure
qui passait par là voilà un
tyrannosauridés qui passait par là et
qui a flingué tout le monde
bah oui on lui il a gagné alors y'a pas
ses traces lui il n'a pas laissé un
macchabée derrière vie qui l'a gagnée on
voyait la l'infinité des l'affinité des
interprétations qu'on peut faire à
partir d'une hta fossé noz et la chasse
en meute c'est pas la plus évidente
pas du tout même et là donc ce que
j'essaye de faire ici c'est pas de
débarquer l'idée de la chasse en meute
j'essaye de vous montrer que les preuves
qu'on a de la chasse en meute elles sont
pas si évidente que ça elles sont elles
sont là je veux dire elles ont été
publiées et où elles sont là mais elles
sont pas si évidente que ça et qu'il
faut il faut quand même avoir une
certaine flexibilité avec la réalité
j'ai envie de dire pour les accepter
sans en discuter
voilà on peut au moins discuter de leur
validité et d'ailleurs je tiens à
souligner je tiens à souligner que cet
article le dit lui même
ils le disent eux mêmes il n'y a aucun
moyen de ne pas prouvé que ces
carnivores n'étaient pas en train de
deux chats rogner sur les sites y pm et
amour rcl machin donc bon c'est une
triple négative alors c'est difficile à
traduire mais en gros y'a aucun moyen
n'a aucun moyen de faire la différence
entre de la vraie prédation et du chat
rognage sur ces sites
c'est ça qu'ils disent mais il est de
notre opinion que ses preuves même
circonstancielle soutiennent que
soutiennent un comportement de prédateur
actifs plutôt que de l'âge du chat
rognage donc en gros ce n'est pas ce
peut-être mais c'est ce que j'ai choisi
de croire
peut-être que ça ne prouve rien mais
c'est ce que j'ai eus choisi de croire
donc quand vous en venez à citer
prometheus 1 comme dernière phrase de
votre article c'est que c'est que ça
sent mauvais c'est que vos preuves elles
sentent mauvais quand même
elles sont elles sont pas fraîche comme
des charognes justement donc c'est ça
que j'aimerais souligner c'est que dans
même maxwell et ostrom dans leur article
massue admettent à la fin de leurs
articles que c'est ça coule pas de
source et qu'ils ont choisi d'y croire
dans une pure dans un pur argument
d'autorité on est dans la plus pure
expression de on a choisi d'y croire et
c'est nous les spécialistes voilà donc
et c'est vrai je veux dire pour
contredire john ostrom il faut quand
même en avoir une paire et la poser sur
la table mais voilà maintenant on a
suffisamment d'articles je vais vous
montrer aujourd'hui on a suffisamment
d'articles pour penser qu' on peut
raisonnablement se permettre de
contredire john ostrom est donc là voici
le site le plus probant parce que là on
a un squelette articulé de ténontosaure
sur le sur le site est mauvaise 682 et
là par contre ce squelette articulé nous
indique beaucoup plus clairement une
thanatos et n'ose donc quelque chose de
plus facile à interpréter en termes de
biocénose et sur ce site il n'y a pas de
démo ni cusm or il n'ya que des dents
qui se sont décrochés de la mâchoire
d'aidé nonick us probablement quand il
était en train de manger le ténontosaure
us et ça du coup ça suggère déjà qu'il
ya eu consommation par dd nonick us de
la carcasse ça le sujet air très
fortement et ça prouve de ce coup là que
les dés nonick us sont pas morts comme
des teubés en essayant de chasser le la
bestiole donc ça exclut du coup la
possibilité que les dynamiques us était
très mauvais à la chasse en plus ils ont
trouvé plein dedans tout en même temps
trop dedans pour que ce soit seulement
un seul individu qui les ai laissés donc
on est face à une bonne preuve que plat
de démonique us ont mangé cette carcasse
par contre on ne sait pas s'ils l'ont
chassé
on sait qu'ils ont mangé mais c'était
peut-être du charognard
en tout cas il n'y a pas de traces y'a
pas de trace par exemple d'une morsure
d'un tyrannosauridés qui montrerait que
c'est le tyrannosauridés qui a tué le
ténontosaure riches il n'y a que les
traces de dynamique us donc c'est vrai
que là pour le coup on est sur une sur
une preuve circonstancielle d'ordre
supérieur voilà mais ça reste une preuve
circonstancielle on n'a pas de trace de
chasse sur cet animal
mais on a au moins la trace que dd
dominique us s'ils sont mis à plusieurs
pour le manger
mais c'est aussi ce que font ces les
crocodiles les crocodiles quand les
quand les guides nous migrent ils
s'agglutinent au niveau du passage des
gnous sur les rivières et dès qu'il ya
un genou qui se fait tuer par un des
crocodiles tous les crocodiles le mange
donc ça veut pas dire qu'ils chassent en
meute ça veut juste dire qu'ils
profitent tous du repas parce qu'il en a
assez pour tout le monde et puis c'est
pareil pour les varans de komodo les
varans de komodo s'ils repèrent 6 il ya
plus d'un warrant qui repèrent une proie
facile mais de grande taille bien ils
vont s'y mettre à plusieurs ils vont pas
forcément se taper dessus
ils vont pas forcément se taper dessus
ils vont s'y mettre à plusieurs mais ça
veut pas dire qu'ils coopèrent ça veut
pas dire qu'ils chassent en meute la
chasse en meute c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement près 6 1
ça demande une coordination ça demande
un réseau social
ça demande un système nerveux qui
soutient ce réseau social
ça demande des moyens de communication
qui pour pour communiquer dans un
travers ce réseau social ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup de choses hein ça ça
demande justement du que les petits que
les juvéniles soit soit attentif à ce
que font les adultes donc les juvéniles
doivent rester avec les adultes ce qui
implique du soin parental enfin vous
voyez hein c'est c'est quelque chose
c'est un tissu en fait de d'hypothèses
la chasse en meute s'est pas seulement
une hypothèse ils chassent ensemble ils
chassent pas ensemble non non vous
faites un tissu d'hypothèses quand vous
dites chassent en meute parce que
chassent en meute c'est extrêmement
spécifique et c'est un comportement
extrêmement complexe bref donc cet
article qui est l'article massue quand
vous entendez quelqu'un vous dire où
quand vous même vous dites on a retrouvé
des nonick us tous ensemble ça veut dire
qu'il faut si lisez tous ensemble autour
d'un ornithologue ça veut dire qu'ils
chasser en meute
vous citez en fait cet article là et cet
article là il est moyennement pro ben
voilà c'est maintenant on a eu d'autres
exemples de possibles scènes de chasse
en meute
il ya par exemple eu cet article dans
national geographic donc c'est pas un
vrai rétable article en réalité c'est un
rapport de découverte
sur une sur un site qui n'a pas encore
été pleinement étudié qui n'a pas encore
été publiée dans une revue à comité de
lecture comme comme ce que je vais vous
montrer donc c'est quelque chose qui est
pas encore officiellement accepté on va
dire mais c'est un site où on trouve
plein du tas raptor et ce site où on
trouve plein du tas raptor il est
souvent mis en avant comme étant la
preuve que vu qu'on appela d'utah raptor
les utah raptor aussi chasser en meute
et c'est donc c'est un des arguments
forts pour généraliser le comportement
des drôme et enfin des raptor ddd nonick
us pardon à tous les drom et aux orres
donc à tous les raptor et on va même
voir plus tard au cours de cette vidéo
que ce comportement de chasse en meute
maintenant il est même généralisée à
plein de théropodes au moins les têtes
annuler ce qui inclut du coup les
tyrannosauridés les aloses or et c'est
donc
donc c'est important aussi ça pas
seulement des implications pour l'aider
nonick us la chasse en meute c'est que
des nonick us en fait le cas de dénis
cus il a commencé la renaissance des
dinosaures dinosaur renaissance cdc la
découverte de dénis cus qui a mis le feu
à cette renaissance qui a fait partir le
truc et qui du coup a fait naître l'idée
que peut-être les théropodes chasser en
meute et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
vous voyez des théropodes des
tyrannosaures et d un loser qui chassent
en meute dans les reporter de la bbc et
tout ça c'est tout ça c'est parti de
démonique us et le truc c'est qu'on a on
va voir au cours de cette vidéo qui a
pas tellement de preuves de sa main n'a
pas beaucoup en fait même donc là en
voici une autre de ses preuves
encore une fois circonstancielle
puisqu'on a un assemblage du tas raptor
est là où j'aimerais attirer votre
attention c'est que même pour l'auteur
de cet article
on est plutôt face enfin du moins pour
l'instant étant données les données
accessibles au moment où l'article a été
écrit c'est à dire en 2015 je crois
voilà c'est écrit d'ici 2015 donc en
2015 au moment où l'auteur a écrit ces
lignes
l'hypothèse favoriser c'était que les
que les conseillers que c'est que ces
dinosaures ont possiblement été
accumulés dans un se sont possiblement
accumulés à des moments différents dans
un
dans un quick sommes donc dans un sable
mouvant
ou alors ils ont pu mourir tous ensemble
au monde au moment d'un souper sociale
donc voilà la fameuse chasse en meute
qui ce qui aurait tourné horriblement
mal et je pense que la mention
horriblement mal nous rappelle aussi que
ce serait horriblement pas de bol ce
serait horriblement horriblement pas de
bol ce serait horriblement improbable
russie ce serait hautement improbable
comment vous mourrez tous comment
comment un gros paquet d'utah raptor
meurt en mangeant d'autres os sur le
site appartiennent à un herbivores
bipèdes appelé iguanodon un bon donc ils
ont trouvé deux l'herbivore quand mes cd
aube seulement donc y'a qu'il ya
d'autres zoos il n'y a pas un squelette
d'herbivores qui aurait pu attirer tout
il ya quelques au derby bord donc on est
on n'exclut pas encore une fois la
possibilité que tout ça était accumulée
pourra par exemple par une rivière où
par exemple juste après une crue tous
les squelettes ont été accumulées par
lots dont on verra quand ce sera publié
j'ai envie de dire mais pour l'instant
utilisé ça comme une preuve de vie en
groupe de réseau social chez les raptors
et de chasse en meute
c'est un peu fort de café donc troisième
élément un troisième élément ça va être
les traces de prédation et là j'ai pas
mal d'articles au niveau des traces de
prédation à vous montrer donc les traces
de prédation voici un article qui vient
de la revue global géologie écrit par un
chercheur russe qui est très très mal
écrit en très mauvais anglais mais dans
lequel il c'est un article intéressant
parce que il montre ce petit os d'adp
rose or avec des traces de dents
possiblement d'un vélociraptor
possiblement fait par un velociraptor
donc là encore une fois il faut
souligner les hypothèses qui sont faites
c'est peut-être les traces de dents d'un
vélociraptor ça a peut-être été fait du
vivant de l'animal mais c'est un peut
tout aussi bien avoir été fait une fois
qu'il était mort parce qu'il ya pas de
trace de cicatrisation le seul moyen de
prouver qu'une trace a été fait sur un
animal vivant en face
une proie vivante et que du coup cette
proie a été attaquée de son vivant et
non pas juste manger après qu'elle soit
morte c'est de trouver des traces de
cicatrisation et là il n'y a pas de
trace de cicatrisation donc
donc si on trouve pas de trace de
cicatrisation c'est que la proie était
probablement déjà morte
ou alors qu'elle est morte dans la
foulée c'est les deux possibilités mais
donc là pas de trace de cicatrisation
donc on n'exclut pas la possibilité que
l'animal était sharon y est on n'est pas
sûr que c'est un velociraptor et et puis
puis c'est déjà pas mal
j'ai envie de dire c'est déjà pas mal
pour dire oui donc les traces de
morsures pareil c'est pas évident à
c'est pas évident a utilisé comme
argument
donc après on ad'autres d'autres
éléments il ya notamment donc dans cet
article là il ya donc own ra eu qui ont
et non par how revue pardon aux huit
routes raout
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas sûr de la
nationalité de cette personne
donc je je vais arrêter d'essayer de
prononcer son nom
donc ces deux auteurs qui ont publié
dans la revue l'été ya donc une revue
bien côté de paléontologie
on fait une liste de tous les deux tout
les traces de morsures et de blessures
infligées par des dinosaures carnivores
du moins des archosaures carnivores et
possiblement attribuables à des
théropodes donc est ce qu'on y voit
c'est que beaucoup d' attaques ont été
perpétrées par des tyrannosaures
identifié comme appartenant à des
tyrannosaures pour la simple et bonne
raison que tyrannosaure est tellement
grand qu'il laisse des traces de dents
extrêmement reconnaissable en plus les
dents de tyrannosaure une section
rectangulaire contrairement à la plupart
des théropodes qui ont une section plus
tôt allongée donc là on a une section
fortement rectangulaire donc c'est très
facile de reconnaître une empreinte de
dents de tyrannosaure quand elle est là
donc c'est principalement du
tyrannosaure il ya aussi que
tyrannosaure c'est le dernier grand
dinosaure prédateur à avoir vécu donc
c'est le plus récent donc les fossiles
sont mieux préservés ça marche aussi
dans ce sens là et il y en a quand même
une qui a attribué à ain drôme et aux au
rider ouais c'est une dent de ptérosaure
dans un
c'est d'une dent de drôme et aux orres
dans un tibia de ptérosaure donc c'est
l'article suivant articles suivants
donc on a on a vu justement grâce à
cette analyse
non c'était celui-là le numéro 5 voilà
donc grâce à tes cette analyse on a pu
voir une liste des gens qui ont déjà
fait le travail pour nous une liste de
toutes les traces qu'ils ont été
retrouvées préserver sur sur des os des
traces de morsure qui ont été retrouvées
préserver sur des os et ont grâce à eux
ça nous amène directement à ce petit
rosoor enfin cette spécimens de
ptérosaure sur lesquelles il y aurait
des traces de dents de velociraptor donc
ce qu'on voit dans cet article
donc publié par philip currie et rolande
azd jacobsen pardon donc fille pury
c'est un des grands noms de la
paléontologie américaine donc on fait
confiance les yeux fermés j'ai envie de
dire donc on a un os de ptérosaure avec
des traces de dents et une dans la
petite idée si je me trompe si je ne
m'abuse donc une petite dent qui a été
qui a été ici identifié comme
appartenant à un théropodes de type
drôme et aux ors et qui donc s'est cassé
en fait est resté planté dans l'os quand
le drôme et aux orres à grignoter le a
grignoté ce bout de ce bout d'os et ceux
de roméo szohr apparemment c'est un sort
ornitho l'espèce voilà donc c'est pas
des mots ni cus pour le coup c'est soir
nitot l'espèce est là où ça devient
intéressant avec cet article est là où
je pense
on s'approche le plus d'une véritable
preuve d'une chasse en groupe c'est que
ski le ski le précise bien c'est que
c'est un os de ptérosaure à starsky des
gigantesques enfin que énorme comme il
dit est que si cette hausse était énorme
c'est qu'il appartenait à un très grand
thé rose or et si on efface un très
grand père aux orres qui a été bouffé
par un tout petit siros ornitho l'espèce
ce que sera en italie ce test c'est pas
un très très gros drôme et aux orres non
plus donc voilà je vous montre vite fait
la taille d'un sort ornitho liste est
évidemment les reconstruit
shanghai ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais ça
vous donne une idée un ordre d'idée au
moins 2 de la taille du bestiau donc ce
soir nitot l'espèce il n'était pas bien
grand et il a bouffé un ptérosaure qui
était beaucoup plus gros que lui
voyez la taille de la dent par rapport à
la taille de l'os du ppte et rose or et
ça c'est très très intéressant c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce que
comment un animal aussi petit que ça
ornitho l'espèce a pu s'attaquer à un
ptérosaure très très grand parce qu'à la
base c'est ça l'idée qui est si
séduisante avec les l'aider nonick us
qui chassent en meute c'est que pour
pouvoir abattre une proie aussi grande
qu'un ténor aux russes il y aurait fallu
qu'ils s'y mettent à plusieurs ce qui
semble assez logique
encore faut-il encore une fois encore
faut-il admettre qu'ils l'ont abattu
qu'il n'était pas juste là pour le
charnier mais là avec ce petit rosa on a
une preuve définitive que un petit drôme
et aux orres a mordu dans un os de
grandpré rose or là il n'y a pas de
doute là dessus
maintenant la seule véritable question
c'est est-ce qu'il l'a fait quand le
ptérosaure était vivant ou quand le
ptérosaure était mort et ça c'est pas
c'est pas gagné on peut pas le savoir
on peut pas le savoir il ya beaucoup
d'éléments de 7
il ya beaucoup d'éléments de cette étude
qui indique que l'os a été directement
attaquée donc ça veut dire que le le
velociraptor disons il s'en prenait pas
à la chair il s'en prenait à loos donc
il n'était pas en train de manger les
meilleures parties savaient que les
chasseurs généralement ceux se paye la
part du lion j'ai envie de dire se paye
la part du lion et ils mangent les
morceaux les plus tendres les plus
nutritifs et puis ils laissent ils
laissent la charogne aux charognards et
donc la place si on a un animal qui me
les qui laissait des coups de dents dans
dans l'os c'est que globalement les
bonnes les bons morceaux étaient déjà
partis donc ça suggère ça que ça suggère
si on part du principe que ce soir on it
all est s
a abattu un ptérosaure alors il y a
fallu qu'ils s'y mettent à plusieurs et
donc ça suggère une chasse en meute
d'autant que pour abattre un ptérosaure
font quand même planifié aussi qu'il ya
un moment il faut qu'ils se posent le
ptérosaure parce qu'un thé rose or ça
vole donc faut planifier les attaques
pour quand le ptérosaure va se poser
c'est ça demande quand même une certaine
coordination donc si on part du principe
que ça ornitho l'espèce a abattu son
côté rose or il a fallu qu'ils s'y
mettre à plusieurs et il a fallu qui se
coordonnent mais ce fossile à lui tout
seul
suggère plutôt que le sort ni tollé
steiss déjà on n'a qu'une seule dent
donc il est possible qu'ils aient eu
qu'un seul individu ça déjà vous rendre
faut en tenir compte
donc il ya une seule dent et donc on a
de la preuve que d'un seul individu
et de deux
donc pas forcément un groupe et de deux
et ben c'est pas les morceaux du lion
qu'il a grignoté c'est les morceaux ccd
restant quoi de la charogne probablement
donc on n'exclut pas un comportement de
charognard voire même on est plutôt
favorable à un comportement de
charognard est ici particulièrement il
n'évoque même pas la possibilité d'une
chasse en meute 1 dans cet article
et idem j'ai trouvé un autre article qui
qui suggère que des raptors ont pu s'en
prendre à des ptérosaures donc voilà un
article très clairement intitulé les
ptérosaures comme une source de
nourriture pour les petits drôme et aux
orres ça ça ne peut être plus clair
donc on a un velociraptor donc voici la
cage thoracique du vélociraptor ici avec
son/sa scapula donc les pôles les côtes
ici et à l'intérieur il ya un os de
ptérosaure annonce de grands enfin un
petit os mais vous voyez c'est un petit
fragment d'os d'un grand ptérosaures et
c'est à l'intérieur de la cage
thoracique donc ça peut très fortement
suggéré que cette terre aux ce thé rose
or s'est fait bouffer directement par le
velociraptor
et ça a du goût encore une fois ça
suggère que des petits velociraptor
pouvait pouvait manger du moins du grand
ptérosaures pouvez manger du grand père
aux ors et pourquoi pas s'attaquer à eux
mais encore une fois ce n'est qu'un
squelette de velociraptor sur lequel on
a retrouvé sa non pas plusieurs
et de deux le truc c'est qu'on a aucune
trace de marque ou de déformations qui
peuvent être attribuées à des sucs
digestifs et ça c'est extrêmement
important
ça peut sembler un détail mais c'est
extrêmement important ça peut sembler à
détail parce qu'on pourrait se dire bah
ouais il a avalé il est mort tout de
suite après
voilà il n'y a pas eu le temps si on
veut d'une action des sucs digestifs
alors oui mais non il ya une autre
possibilité c'est que cette hausse la
pareille c'est que cette eau cela n'est
peut-être pas en condition de thanatos
et n'osent il est peut-être en condition
de ta fausse et n'osent à savoir que le
velociraptor est mort le squelette
il commence à se décomposer la cage
thoracique est ouverte
hélas un os de ptérosaure fini dedans
pour une raison ou pour une autre
alors le fait que le squelette soit
complètement articulé comme on voit là
ça suggère qu'il était tenu par une
couche de peau au moins momifié donc ça
tendrait à exclure cette hypothèse
par contre ça n'empêche qu'il faut pas
négliger le fait il ya pas de trace de
sucs digestifs
pas de trace de sucs digestifs ça veut
dire qu'encore une fois même si on
regarde une thanatos haineuse il est
possible que ce con de velociraptor ce
soit étouffée avec est là pour le coup
là pour le coup il veut enfin il le
suggère à demi mot mais il ne suggère
quand même parce que là ce qui suggère
c'est que du coup le en gros le
ptérosaure était beaucoup trop grand et
que les laits drôme et aux orres qui
consommaient noces probablement consommé
de l'os probablement parce que il n'y
avait pas grand chose restant sur la
carcasse
ou peut-être même et éthique seulement à
la recherche des minéraux donc ils
consommaient de l'os juste pour enrichir
son corps en minéraux pour construire
finalement son propre squelette à lui
quoi donc il est en tout cas ils
suggèrent que il ya peu il ya peu de
chance qu'un petit drôme et aux orres
comme ça se soit enfilé un gros petit
rose or comme ça est dû et de fait dans
l'idée qu'il ya derrière c'est
finalement est-ce que ce
est-ce qu'il a pas eu plus les yeux plus
gros que le ventre et que là pour le
coup il se soit pas carrément il tout
fait avec
et encore une fois on regarde une
thanatos et n'ose donc c'est possible
c'est pas une scène de vie qu'on voit
c'est pas à raptor en train de digérer
un os qu on est en train de voir on est
là ce qu'on regarde c'est un raptor avec
un os par un raptor mort avec un os pas
digéré dans l'oesophage
vous voyez le procédé c'est un raptor
mort avec un os pas encore digéré dans
le tube digestif on va pas dire
l'oesophage mais dans le tube digestif
et dans la plus tôt la partie thoracique
du tube digestif donc pas vraiment dans
l'estomac ou dans les intestins coin
donc on est peut-être au mieux dans le
gésier au mieux voire carrément dans
l'oesophage hélas hélas est presque sûre
qui s'est étouffé comme un conte donc
vous faire attention avec les thanatos
et nous faut faire très très attention
c'est pas un problème c'est ça veut pas
dire que moi j'interprète ça de cette
façon un ça veut dire que l'on ne peut
pas exclure cette possibilité
attention moi j'ai très envie de croire
que dès que ce raptor a consommé cette
hausse et qu'il est mort après une
raison qui n'a rien à voir et que donc
ils mangeaient effectivement du thé rose
or mais on ne peut pas exclure la
possibilité que ce raptor à manger un
truc qui n'est qu'il n'était pas sensé
manger et qu'il est mort voilà ils
n'étaient pas adaptés à manger ce truc
là et donc eu pareil il est hors de
question il est même hors de question
dans leur cas d'évoquer la possibilité
de la chasse en meute là pour le coup il
se demande juste si c'est du chat
rognage ou de la prédation ils vont même
pas jusqu'à pousser a poussé le bouchon
jusqu'à l'achat 100 m parce
qu'évidemment cissé du charognard la
chasse en meute et exclut de base donc
il n'ya pas de n'y a pas vraiment de
questions à se poser
les autres arguments qui sont amenées
pour défendre la la possibilité de la
chasse en meute chez les ch et les drom
et aux autres idées et en particulier
chez des nonick us parce que j'ai des
nonick us on a c'est le premier comme je
le disais chez qui ça a été évoqué cette
possibilité donc si on disqualifie
démonique us ça fout un sacré coup de
mou
à toute la théorie donc là ce qu'on a vu
plus c'est qu'en gros on a pas vraiment
de preuve définitive de chasse en meute
chez les drogués aux ors et
particulièrement chez démonique us n'y a
pas vraiment de preuve non
circonstancielle voilà on va réutiliser
le mot circonstancielle dont il n'y a
pas de preuve
mieux que circonstancielle c'est ouais
on a on a une il ya une probabilité
élevée de trouver des dénommés qui
sautent ur de carcasses de grands
animaux
il ya déjà dédé ne nie qu'il ya des
vélos sierra un velociraptor retrouver
avec une trace de avec un os un grosse
dans le tube digestif
il y a un gros ce das d'arc idée qui a
été retrouvé avec une dent de thornhill
tollé steiss à l'intérieur donc il ya
consommation de grosses proies chez les
ch et les drom et aux or il y a des
preuves de consommation de grosses
proies chez les drogués aux orres
suffisamment pour dire qu' il le faisait
de temps en temps mais on n'a aucune
preuve qu'ils les chassait et comme je
lé deal avec celui qui est pas digéré on
a même plutôt enfin comme je les dis à
travers même tous les la plupart des
exemples que je vous ai montré on a même
très peu de preuves qui les chasseurs
donc donc maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait au final pour prouver qu'il y à
chasse en groupe
ben il y en a certains qui ont proposé
la taille du cerveau non pardon pardon
on va commencer par les traces donc il y
en a certains qui ont proposé va trouver
des empreintes de pas de raptor tous
ensemble ça montrerait que c'est raptor
vivait en groupe et donc tissu social et
donc possiblement chassent en meute ont
déjà trouvé là ce qu'ils ont trouvé ces
des empreintes parallèle de deux drôme
et aux aurait pu s' et ils ont aussi un
autre site avec des vélociraptors rictus
donc bref des empreintes de pas
attribués à des drones et aux orres très
reconnaissable parce qu'elles n'ont que
deux doigts vu que le troisième droits
élevés pour pour la griffe pour que la
griffe soient tenus en l'air les les
empreintes de drôme et aux orres sont
les seuls empreintes ou qui n'ont que
deux doigts donc ses empreintes
il n'y a pas trop de doute sur le fait
qu'elles appartiennent à aider drôme et
aux ors et on a au moins 1 2
trois pistes de ses empreintes à deux
doigts qui sont parallèles sur un site
ce qui veut dire qu'ils mouillent qu'ils
se bougent est tous dans la même
direction
et ça c'est intéressant parce que s'il
bouge est tous dans la direction c'est
que possiblement il bougeait tous
ensemble dans la même direction
maintenant le truc c'est est-ce que ils
ont bougé tous en même temps dans la
même direction
et ça on peut pas le prouver encore une
fois on n'a pas le timing sur les
empreintes de pas donc on peut pas
prouver qu'ils ont bougé tous en même
temps dans la même direction
donc là on a même des rites de courant
ce qui suggère qu'on était sur un
endroit qui était fréquemment recouvert
par de l'eau probablement une plage donc
ça veut dire qu'on a un intervalle de
temps en gros entre
on a un intervalle de temps qui
correspond à la marée quoi donc un
intervalle d'un gros d'un gros 6 heures
si vous voulez de pour que toutes ces
empreintes se forment donc ça c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on appellerait un
intervalle de quelques minutes là pour
parler d'un groupe faudrait avoir la
preuve qu'ils étaient tous ensemble et
ce qui pourrait suggérer que il n'était
pas forcément tous ensemble c'est raptor
c'est le fait qu'il y à d'autres
empreintes de dinosaures qui bouge dans
la même direction et qu'ils
appartiennent définitivement à d'autres
dinosaures puisqu'on voit les trois
doigts imprimez la et et toutes les
empreintes de ce site en fait elles sont
parallèles elles vont pas toutes dans la
même direction mais par contre elles
sont toutes parallèle ce qui suggère que
la cette direction en particulier donc
la direction qui correspond à ce qu'ils
ont mis le nord sur leur figure ça c'est
bizarre ça à faire des figures on met
les voiles nord bref cette direction là
la direction oblique que j'indique
maintenant en fait c'était la direction
privilégiée de déplacement de tout ce
qui passait par là et ça c'est pas
négligeable comme information ça veut
dire que un animal qui passait par là a
plus de probabilités de prendre cette
direction pour une raison ou pour une
autre
ça arrive souvent par exemple que les
que les que les carnivores longe les
plages pour trouver des carcasses par
exemple pour trouver des carcasses
rejetés par la mer pendant la marée
haute justement donc et donc du coup
tous les to les carnivores vont longer
la plage dans la même direction 100% pas
sans pour autant passer en même temps et
sans pour autant collaborer d'ailleurs
c'est plus du chat rognage typiquement
là pour le coup c'est définitivement un
comportement de charognard
donc voilà on ses empreintes parallèle
devait de raptor possiblement
velociraptor puisqu'on est en asie de
raptor de drôme et aux orres en soit
elle ne prouve pas grand chose voilà et
c'est le seul essai à ma connaissance la
seule occurrence d'empreintes parallèle
chez des raptor dont pas concluants et
ans que le deuxième truc c'est le
cerveau donc les gens ont proposé que
parce que les drones et aux ordres ont
un tel gros cerveau il était forcément
hyper intelligent et capable de vie
sociale
bon au delà du para enfin au delà des
raisons évidentes qu'on aurait à faire
le parallèle entre gros cerveau et
intelligence parce que je vais pas faire
la liste de toutes les raisons qu'il y
aurait un contredire cet argument mais
voilà au delà du de simplement aller
dans cette direction on va on va
observer si des nonick us enfin si les
drom et aux orres ont effectivement à
servent aussi gros que ça et en
l'occurrence c'est pas forcément ce
n'est pas forcément le cas là on a donc
à ma connaissance il ya que deux
cerveaux de drôme et aux orres qui ont
été étudiées faille en a qu'un seul qui
a été réellement étudié et il y à une
figure de détonique us donc ici vous
avez trop de trop dont qui a été
fortement à l'étudier éléctro dont il a
effectivement un gros cerveau c'est un
petit drone s'est pas adressé aux
autorités c'est bien le problème c'est
un trop de petits dés donc c'est un
petit coup zadeh c'est un cousin de
petite taille des drôme et aux ors et
lui il a effectivement un gros cerveau
il a un cerveau qui est alors en
fonction des indices qu'on utilise pour
comparer la taille des cerveaux trop
dont il peut avoir un cerveau soit
légèrement plus petit que les oiseaux
soient de taille équivalente à celui des
oiseaux avec un plus petit cerveau voilà
donc trop dont il a un taille
il a une taille de cerveau qui est quand
même comparable à celle de certains
oiseaux
bien que la morphologie soit extrêmement
différentes par contre dès nonick us qui
se trouve là donc là c'est un cerveau
composites
enfin un cerveau et non une boîte
crânienne le moulage d'une boîte
crânienne reconstitué en composites à
partir de deux autres spécimens de deux
spécimens cette boîte crânienne voyait
que ella ella certains points communs
avec trop d'hommes elle a beaucoup plus
de points communs avec tyrannosaure ici
vous avez des bulbes olfactifs qui sont
pédonculé est très long vous avez c'est
une petite bosse qui correspond aux
hémisphère au lieu d'une grosse bosse
6,6 pour les hémisphères chez trop dont
vous avez une petite bosse ici qui
correspond au cervelet dont ça s'est
passé chez trop donc vous avez une
énorme glande pituitaire ici enfin une
fausse pituitaire pour la glande
pituitaire ici mais surtout ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant à voir c'est au delà des
similitudes et des différences c'est
surtout l'échelle
quand vous comparez l'échelle du cerveau
de trop dont à l'échelle de détonique us
vous voyez que l'échelle et la même hors
des nonick us il est deux voire trois
fois trois fois plus gros que trop aux
dons donc ça lui fait un cerveau tout
petit donc si si vous comparez trop donc
à un oiseau moyens modernes démonique us
c'était clairement une autruche quoi ce
n'était pas une fusée donc le gros
cerveau pour soutenir et essai le seul
drôme et aux or à ma connaissance pour
lequel on a un cerveau du mois un
cerveau bien étudié donc c'est pas
forcément gagné et quand on regarde le
cerveau d'archaeopteryx ceci n'est pas
le cerveau d'arqués si c'est le cerveau
d'archaeopteryx quand on regarde le
cerveau d'archaeopteryx par rapport à la
taille du corps le cerveau
d'archaeopteryx et même plus petit que
celui de trop dont curieusement par
contre il a plus de points communs avec
les oiseaux au niveau de sa morphologie
les hémisphères sont plus gros et voyez
les lobes optiques sont très fortement
développée et est séparé par le cervelet
au milieu ça c'est un caractère
d'oiseaux aussi donc le cerveau est plus
proche de celui des oiseaux mais il est
plus petit par contre en comparaison la
taille du corps que celui de trop aux
dons est hélas il ne donne pas la taille
exacte du cerveau de détonique us donc
je donc la seule chose que je peux dire
à propos du cerveau des nonick us c'est
que à vue de barre d'échelle le cerveau
était de la même taille à peu près
cottereau donc pour un animal qui était
quasiment trois fois plus gros qui
étaient deux à trois fois plus gros donc
c'est pas forcément un animal
extrêmement intelligent et là où je veux
en venir aussi c'est que ça veut pas du
coup l'ancêtre commun de trop de dreux
de détonique us et de archéoptéryx vu
que denis cus et archaeopteryx sont
plutôt des petits cerveaux comparé à
trop long l'ancêtre commun de tout ce
beau monde là avait pas forcément un
gros cerveau c'est pas forcément ça
coule pas forcément de source que c'est
peut-être que trop donc il y avait un
gros cerveau finale ou que les
troodontidés donc affaire à suivre sur
le cerveau mais en tout cas pour
l'instant on n'est pas trop sur des
preuves que que les trop donc que les
drom et aux orres avait des au cerveau
et en particulier d'ennemis puce et le
clou dans le cercueil des dîners drôme
et aux orres chassé en troupeau enfin en
meute
c'est un article de carpenter qui le
plant avant même la l'étude la toute
dernière étude qui a été publié et qui a
fait l'objet de notre palais aux news 1
c'est kenneth carpenter qui le plante
dans cet article en fait où il revient
sur le spécimen qui s'appelle the
fighting père ou le combat en fait entre
velociraptor et et proto ceratops qui a
été retrouvé dans le désert de gobi donc
c'est un magnifique squelette donc je
vais vous montrer une photo maintenant
une photo hd parce que là les photos sur
l'article sont pas très joli mais voilà
vous avez un velociraptor parfaitement
conservés parfaitement identifiable et
vous avez proto ceratops ici la vue du
dessus vous avez le bec ici la
collerette à l'arrière la colonne
vertébrale là que le bassin ici et les
bras ici donc et le ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'avant bras de
dudu raptor se trouve à l'intérieur du
bec du proto ceratops et vous voyez ici
l'avant bras qui a été disloquée par le
bec du proto ceratops pendant tandis que
le velociraptor ici à la jambe qui est
avec sa griffe directement planté dans
le cou du du proto ceratops donc
possiblement en train de viser l'artère
carotide
donc là en terme de thanatos et n'osent
on à ce qui se fait de mieux et on peut
raisonnablement imaginer que cette
thanatos et n'osent reflète une
biocénose pour une raison pour une
raison justement que carpenter développe
ici c'est que il est possible l'un des
seuls moyens possibles pour qu'une telle
scène se préserve c'est que en fait les
animaux soient morts en se battant et
ensuite et seulement ensuite ce soit ce
soit momifié en fait ils se sont
modifiées à cause du climat très sec du
désert de gobi à l'époque moi c'était un
climat très saisonnier donc avec des dés
été très chaud et très rude
donc ils se sont modifiées dieu à ce
climat très sec
et que au bout d'un moment ils ont fini
par être recouvert par du sable pendant
une tempête de sable par exemple enfin
quelque chose comme ça donc c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'ils proposent et alors là où
ça devient intéressant
là où ça devient intéressant au niveau
de l'interprétation c'est que en fait ce
qu'il dit c'est que pourquoi le
velociraptor enfin pourquoi la paire n'a
pas été n'a pas été sharon y est c'est
une question qui est extrêmement
intéressante pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas été charniers ben parce qu'ils
étaient tout seul parce qu'il y avait
que eux et pourquoi il y avait que eux
parce que ville aussi raptor était tout
seul il ne chassait pas en meute
voilà et en plus et en plus si on y
réfléchit bien si velociraptor chasser
en meute et ben eh ben on aurait on
aurait eu ce proto ceratops qui se
serait fait attaquer par les côtés par
les autres velociraptor pendant que
celui là finalement le disent très fière
en offrant son bras en pâture à la seule
partie vraiment dangereuse de l'anatomie
d'un proto ceratops à savoir son bec
donc donc finalement pendant que celui
là il faisait diversion les autres
velociraptor l'aurait attaqué si les
velociraptor chasser en meute
1 les deux autres raptor qu'il n'avait
même pas vu à cause de sa collerette
donc voyez là là là la stratégie
professeur grant ne marche absolument
pas là le premier raptor qui fait
diversion pendant que les deux autres
l'attaquent par le côté ça a visiblement
pas marché est ce qu'il faut bien se
rendre selon qu'il faut bien se rendre
compte c'est qu'on pourrait peut-être
être face à une scène où justement comme
je le disais c'est une thanatos et n'ose
donc peut-être que ce coup là ça a mal
tourné
je vous vois en train de retourner mes
propres arguments contre moi mais là où
ça devient intéressant en fait c'est que
cette scène pour qu'une scène comme ça
soit préservée faut essayer de vous
représenter le nombre de fois qu'une
scène comme ça a dû se produire parce
qu'il n'y a qu'un seul
on estime qu'il y a qu un seul individu
sur dix mille voire même un seul
individu sur un million alors
arrondissant à un sur cent mille qui se
fossilise donc pour qu'une scène comme
ça se retrouve préserver de cette façon
imaginez combien de fois elle a dû se
reproduire pour finalement être
fossilisés ça ben c'est quand même un
truc de fou à se rendre compte des
chiffres là c'est un truc de fou
donc ça ça soutient très fortement que
velociraptor s'en prenait à proto
ceratops face à face mano à mano
quasiment systématiquement ce qui va
d'ailleurs assez bien avec le sort
ornitho liste est ce qu on a vu tout à
l'heure et avec l'autre velociraptor
qu'on la retrouvait avec un morceau de
avec un morceau de de terre aux orres
aussi dans le dans le tube digestif
donc faut faut bien se représenter que
une scène pareille ça se fossilise pas
tous les deux jours et que du coup pour
que pour que ça arrive faut augmenter
les probabilités que ça arrive par faut
que cela atteigne des sommets
à moins d'avoir un énorme monstrueux
coup de bol mais bon on est bien
d'accord que la plupart du temps on va
partir du principe que les fossiles
reflète ce qui se passe en moyenne parce
qu'il sera pas ce qui se passe
extrêmement rare ben voilà pensez par
exemple aux reptiles qui avait été
retrouvée le reptile fossiles qui avait
été retrouvé je crois que c'était au
laos ou en thaïlande je sais plus en
asie du sud est qui avait deux têtes
bon ben c'est pas pour rien que c'est un
reptile à deux têtes qu'on retrouve
fossilisés attend un bébé reptiles à
deux têtes qu'on retrouve fossilisés
c'est parce que ça arrive assez
communément chez les reptiles de naître
avec deux têtes le jour on trouve ça
chez un mammifère là j'applaudis des
deux mains j'applaudis déjà dès demain
pour trouver un fossile à deux têtes de
reptiles
mais là où l'on trouvera ça chez un
mammifère alors là ce sera ce sera
extraordinaire parce que ça n'arrive
presque jamais chez les mammifères les
spécimens à deux têtes du moins pas
qu'ils survivent aussi longtemps ou pas
suffisamment longtemps pour fossilisés
de façon décente
voilà donc donc c'est ça qu'il faut se
représenter c'est la prob l'infini un
probabilité qu'un tel comportement se
fossilise si jamais ce n'était pas le
comportement normal de cette bestiole
voilà c'est ça qui font imprimer donc
c'est un argument très fort pour dire
que le velociraptor chasser seul et en
plus il ya le fait que et en plus il ya
le fait qu'ils n'ont pas été charbonnier
donc il y avait pas d'autres
velociraptor dans le coin qu'ils sont
probablement complètement desséchées
donc ya pas eu de velociraptor dans le
coin pendant un moment
il était vraiment tout seul de chez tout
seul il faut quand même plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois pour que
ça se dessèchent un truc pareil
on voit bien la dessiccation parce que
justement là que est relevé et la nuque
et repliée donc c'est la fameuse
contraction post mortem de des ligaments
de la colonne vertébrale
donc on voit cette destination qui se
reflète là et puis well et les fantasmes
de les fantasmes de gens qui croient que
c'est une dune qui les ensevelit pan qui
se battaient s'il est si la dune les
avait enseveli pendant qu'ils se battent
et il aurait essayé de s'échapper de la
dune
donc tout ça toute cette scène là ne
serait pas préservée de cette façon ils
ont réessayé au moins de se barrer le
poids même
même en imaginant que le poids de la
dune et puis de façon oui le poids de la
dune s'effondrant sur eux les ça ça
aurais pas tenus dans cette position
donc c'est vraiment là il ya vraiment
que en s'imaginant qu'ils ont desséché
comme ça que qu'ils sont morts comme ça
qu'ils sont desséchés comme ça que ça a
pu se produire et que au bout d'un
moment les momies ont fini par être
recouverte par du sable parce que
justement la momification rajoute au
processus la dimension du temps c'est
parce que c'est s'imaginer que ça s'est
fait en instantané c'est un joli
fantasme mais ça m'étonnerait
ça m'étonnerait et puis du coup c'est ce
que carpenter dit aussi donc là on a la
preuve ultime que au moins velociraptor
ne chassait pas du tout en meute et
surtout pas de la façon dont s'est
présenté dans jurassic park
là pour le coup c'est mort et enterré et
on a effectivement une planète au semnoz
qui ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
à une biocénose
alors maintenant du coup qu'est ce
qu'ils mangeaient s'ils mangeaient pas
des grosses pro à 6 ils pouvaient pas
chassé en troupeau enfin s'il pouvait
pas chasser en meute et que du coup il
pouvait pas manger des grosses prod
qu'est ce que ça mange est un raptor et
ben on a des contenus stomacaux de
raptor figurez vous on a des contenus
stomacaux de roméo zor est encore une
fois au canada dit que réellement la
consommation de grosses proies à part
celui celui qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
avec à part celui qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure mais je le rappelle l'acide
n'avait pas attaqué le truc là on va
vous montrer des trucs où la cid a
attaqué le coup donc là microraptor on a
des l'a71 microraptor et à l'intérieur
il ya des restes d'un petit animal ce
petit animal étant un oiseau donc
et là on en a dans la partie haute mais
aussi dans la partie basse de du tube
digestif donc et on a hâte à cas ci
dessus et dislocation des restes donc on
a on a vraiment une action qui a été
fait en fait sur ce par les sucs
digestifs par le processus digestif
sur le reste de l'oiseau et du coup ça
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant déjà c'est que
ça montre que microraptor manger des
proies plus petit que lui puisqu'il
mangeait des oiseaux de type et nantes
urnes it in donc donc c'est des petits
oiseaux quoi vous voyez là il ya une
représentation avec microraptor ici et
la taille de l'oiseau à l'échelle donc
c'est les oiseaux qui sont plus petits
que lui donc là on a attaque de proa qui
sont plus petit que lui ai d'ailleurs
par la même attaque de proa volante ce
qui montre que microraptor volet donc
tout à l'heure je vous ai montré là les
ptérosaures et on aurait pu se dire que
éventuellement c'est très peu probable
qu'ils se soient attaqués à un
ptérosaure puisque puisque les
ptérosaures volée et pas les
velociraptor mais là pour le coup
microraptor bon si microraptor n'était
pas une exception parmi les drom et aux
orres ce qui a tendance à être confirmée
ce qui a tendance à être de plus en plus
confirmés la plupart des drôme et aux
oreilles des avaient des plumes
microraptor je crois que c'est un des
seuls qui avaient des plumes asymétrique
donc mais ça ce j'ai un petit doute là
dessus donc il faudra mais bref
il avait au moins des capacité à planer
des microraptor et donc c'est pas
complètement approché impossible que ses
proches parents aient eu des capacités
proches donc bon certainement pas aussi
développée que les ptérosaures 1 ceci
étant dit il voulait certainement pas
aussi bien que des ptérosaures donc là
on a un énorme hit in et là on a un
autre microraptor ici avec un contenu
stomacal préserver et ce coup là c'est à
petit reptile
c'est un lézard donc pareil voici le
microraptor et on a de tout enfin on a
deux des restes d'un petit les armes et
dont le crâne que vous voyez ici vous
voyez la mandibule ici est le haut du
crâne qui se trouve dans la partie
plutôt basse de du tube digestif donc
encore une fois plus tôt dans la partie
où la digestion avait raisonnablement
commencé et dans ce que j'aime bien avec
cet article c'est qu'ils nous disent
c'est la quatrième fois qu'un spécimen
de mes crocs à raptor est décrit avec
des restes ingéré dans la cavité dans la
cavité digestive à savoir des élans et
que ça contenait des énormes encore dit
lolo type contenait un mammifère et on a
même du poisson
donc on a vraiment une variété de proies
qui vont des oiseaux aux petits
mammifères et même du poisson
le tout et chacun d'entre eux étant plus
petit que microraptor lui même donc pas
de pas de preuves possibles de chasse on
ne te à travers ça et la dernière la
dernière le dernier comportement qui est
préservée chez les vélos c'est rachel et
raptor c'est là c'est un comportement de
creusage de creusage par un dinosaure
parent drôme et aux orres
donc ils ont retrouvé des traces des
traces possibles en fait de griffes de
drôme et aux orres qui ont servi à
creuser pour déterrer à mammifères bon
alors là pour le coup c'est ni internet
au semnoz ni une tare fossé noz c'est
une trace fossiles et les traces
fossiles c'est comme les empreintes de
passer des choses qui ont été faites du
vivant de l'animal donc ça peut être
interprété comme une biocénose alors
après est ce que c'était vraiment pour
déterrer un mammifère est est ce que
c'était et puis même si c'était pour
déterrer un mammifère est ce que c'était
vraiment pour le bouffer je veux dire on
peut on peut spéculer mais en tout cas
si on a une des traces de creusage pour
déterrer un mammifère bas c'est
qu'encore une fois on a une trace active
d'un seul drôme et aux orres en train de
chasser une proie plus petit donc là
pour le coup ce serait une trace active
de chasse mais pas d'une proie plus
grosse mais c'est le genre de tracé
encore une fois c'est le genre de traces
qui vous montrent que c'est possible de
prouver que les raptor chasser en meute
mais il faut trouver des traces fossiles
qui montre du du raptor avec une proie
donc plusieurs raptor suivant une proie
donc des pistes parallèles et avec un
chevauchement des empreintes entre les
empreintes des raptor et celle des
aisselles des proies qui permet de dire
que que les deux que les deux séries
d'empreintes ont été faites en même
temps c'est à dire qu'il faudrait au
moins une empreinte de raptor qui se
fait sur un primé par une empreinte de
la proie est ensuite une des empreintes
de la proie qui se fait sur un primé par
une empreinte de raptor ce qui voudrait
dire qu'en fait les deux empreintes
enfin les deux séries d'empreintes n'ont
pu qu'être fait en même temps parce que
sinon soit c'est toutes les empreintes
de raptor qui rendent qui passe par
dessus tout les empreintes de la proie
ou soit celle inverse si c'est la proie
qui est passé longtemps après les rapts
or donc c'est possible de montrer tout
ça c'est possible mais il faut vraiment
une condition absolument exceptionnel de
préservation ou on aurait plusieurs
empreintes de drôme et aux orres qui
entrecroise les empreintes une série
d'empreintes da d'une proie plus grosses
qu'eux
donc possiblement d'un ornithologue donc
c'est pas complètement à démontrable
mais ça va voilà c'est le seul type de
fossiles qui réellement pourrait vous
permettre de prouver ça ou alors
justement trouver un drôme et aux orres
à drôme et aux orres avec un os à
l'intérieur de sa cavité digestive qui a
déjà comme un os d'un gros than it aux
potes donc par exemple une phalange ça
pas besoin d'être un gros os mais il
faut que ce soit un homme d'un gros
animal donc ça peut être juste une
phalange mais une grosse phalange dans
l'estomac et bien digéré ce qui montre
que l'animal a vécu après l'avoir avalé
pas comme le pas comme le coût du papier
rose or parce que si il est mort en
l'avalant bas c'est qu'il sait juste
étouffé qu'il n'était pas adapté pour ça
et ça c'est parce qu'on veut nous ce
qu'on veut c'est une preuve que ce soit
que ça se soit produit pas une preuve
qui se sont pas une preuve qui s'est
complètement raté en le faisant
et donc là on arrive à l'article de 2007
de roach et brinkmann qui a contredit le
plus vigoureusement le l'hypothèse des
raptor chats sont en mode donc dans cet
article ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
reprennent pas ce qui avait été dit dans
dans maxwell et ostrom
et puis bah ils vous disent exactement
ce que je vous ai dit à savoir que ça ne
prouve rien qu'il est possible que c'est
alors que leurs grosses hypothèse c'est
que les allées raptor se sont chassés
entre eux en fait ils se sont entretués
donc se passer leurs grosses hypothèse
un peu comme le font les warrants
aujourd'hui les warrants vous quand il
ya une proie et qu'il ya beaucoup trop
de prédateurs dessus il commence à se
bouffer entre eux comme ça tout le monde
a de la bouffe
voilà sauf ceux qui sont morts mais mais
voilà c'est leur hypothèse à eux leur
grosse idée ladd a eu c'est ça s'est
basé sur un seul spécimen à savoir une
des vertèbres qui est attaché à une
griffe qui portent des traces en fait de
morsures dessus donc il ya qu une seule
il ya qu un seul en fait morceaux d'un
des spécimens qui soutient cette théorie
donc je veux dire encore une fois c'est
circonstancielle ça veut pas forcément
dire ça si ça veut dire qu'il ya eu des
traces de dents sur ce spécimen ça veut
pas forcément dire que ça a eu lieu
fraîchement quoi c'est peut-être un de
roméo szohr qui est passé longtemps
après on n'est peut-être pas face à une
scène où tous les raptor se sont
rassemblés autour du thé non aux ordres
du thé non aux ors et on finit par se
marcher dessus et se bouffer les uns les
autres
peut-être qu'il ya trois drôme et aux
orres qui sont morts par hasard à côté
d'un thé nos 2 or et que plusieurs
plusieurs jours après il ya un autre de
roméo szohr qui est passée par là et qui
s'est dit oh tiens il ya à manger et
crack
et voilà mais bon donc ils ont toutes un
argument pour dire que ceci ne s'est pas
produit de cette façon mais bon encore
une fois équilibre entre eux thanatos et
nausées biocénose vous connaissez la
chanson mais voilà le ils interprètent
cela comme des agressions
intraspécifique donc à l'intérieur de
l'espèce ensuite ils vont ils vont donc
oui est-ce qu'on ce que je vous dis là
avec les varans de komodo qui qui qui
attaquent tous une proie en même temps
sans pour autant coopérer c'est ce qu'on
appelle du commensalisme voilà donc ils
bossent en même temps ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils bossent ensemble voilà
et puis là il ya un autre site avec
encore une fois tes notes aux russes et
des drôme et aux orres pardon non c'est
un drôme et aux orres en noir pardon
avec du thé nom taurus au tour donc il
présente d'autres sites qui vont dans le
même sens selon lui et donc ce qui
suggère c'est qu'en fait l'hypothèse de
base
quand on fait une étude d'un site où il
ya plusieurs prédateurs ça devrait pas
être que c'est red hat
ça veut pas ça devrait pas être que ces
prédateurs chasser en meute l'hypothèse
de base ça devrait être
les prédateurs ne chassent et pas
forcément en meute est-ce que ce site me
prouve le contraire on devrait pas
partir du principe qu'il chasser en
meute
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hypothèse nul
l'hypothèse de base et c'est ce qu'il
suggère dans cet article c'est lagraulas
grosse idée de cet article c'est qu'on
s'est précipité depuis justement la
découverte d'eau strom on s'est
précipité vers la
vers le l'hypothèse que les prédateurs
chasser en meute et du coup on a un peu
mis de côté notre esprit critique et on
a un peu de me de côté le tout le
concept qu'une thanatos enos c'est pas
une biocénose et tout le concept que des
aussi que des eaux d articuler comme ça
c'est même pas forcément une thanatos et
n'ose d'ailleurs
donc ça c'est sa grosse idée justement
et après il va faire la liste de tous
les spécimens fin de tout les cas où en
fait les assemblages un assemblage de
carnivores de plusieurs carnivores ont
été interprétées abusivement comme des
cas de vie sociale et de chasse en meute
alors avant qu'on en arrive là il ya un
truc très intéressant il parle ici de
hoffenberg qui parle justement de la
façon dont les varans de komodo donc les
zorra ouvre le ventre de leurs proies
pour que leurs viscères se déversent par
gravité donc voilà c'est de là si vous
vous demandiez d'où venait la phrase il
trouvera peut-être levante qui déverse
ses intestins qui est prononcé dans
jurassic park ça vient d'eux hoffenberg
1980 donc c'est une idée qui vient
effectivement d'un article scientifique
merci jack horner d'avoir participé à la
en tant que conseiller scientifique à
jurassic sur jurassic park
l'affluence de la doctrine de la chasse
en meute chez deux pour des nonick us en
tire opus et comment cette doctrine a
influencé l'idée en fait que les
prédateurs chasse chasse est
systématiquement en meute donc donc là
ouais on est sur une doctrine qui a
quasiment 50 ans une idée qui a
quasiment 50 ans a été prononcé dans les
années 60
donc ça fait même un petit peu plus loin
c'est f à 60,11 ça fait 50 ans ça fait à
peu près 50 ans mais voilà depuis elle a
été extrêmement accepté dans
l'inconscient collectif et il ya
plusieurs sites du coup d'assemblage de
plusieurs théropodes qui ont été
proposés comme étant la preuve qu'il
vivait en meute alors que bah c'est
juste d'état nette hausse et nausées
qu'on peut pas définitivement dire que
c'était effectivement des épreuves de
chasse en meute donc par exemple le site
de go ce trench
vous avez tous laissés l'office ben on
n'a que des scellés au physique s'il n'y
a pas des herbivores donc
donc on n'est même pas sûr que ce soit
une scène de chasse alors peut-être
qu'il se rassembler peut-être qu'ils se
sont rassemblés peut-être que c'est un
événement géologique qui les a
rassemblés peut-être que c'est une crue
on en a aucune idée hein on en a aucune
idée c'est ce qu'il explique l'a ensuite
vous avez la carrière de lloyd qui est
la fameuse carrière qui qui a fait
proposé que allosaure chasser en meute
donc souvent ce qui arrive souvent dans
les reportages c'est que vous voyez à
stégosaure ceux coincés dans la boue et
vous vous allez voir plusieurs allosaure
converger pour tuer ce stégosaure et ben
c'est un c'est une reconstitution de ce
qui se passe à la carrière de ce qu'on a
retrouvés à la carrière de cleveland
lloyd et cette reconstitution finalement
elle est en phase i si la reconstitution
que vous avez vu sous-entendez que les
aloses or chasser ensemble c'est c'est
éminemment faux puisqu'on a retrouvé ray
n'est pas moins de 50 individus de
sigean de théropodes différents donc ça
veut pas dire qu'il y avait 50 carnivore
qui chassait tous ensemble la carrière
de lloyd c'est typiquement un piège à
prédateur il ya de la boue des bestioles
qui viennent se coincer dedans ça attire
les carnivores les carnivores se
coincent dedans ça attire plus de
carnivores etc etc
ça peut durer des années comme ça donc
vous avez une accumulation de cadavres
en fait qui se coincent au fur et à
mesure dans la boue et qui n'arrêtent
pas d'attirer plus de carnivore qui
viennent sharon y est donc donc en au
delà même des thunes de ne pas être une
preuve de chasse en meute c'est même une
preuve de charognards pour le coup
trouvent les six espèces qui avait
là-dedans ça veut dire qu'elle était
venue chercher de la charogne
voilà enfin les six genre qui sont venus
chercher de la bouffe là dedans ça veut
dire qu'ils étaient venus chercher de la
charogne et donc 44 sont des aloses or
donc si vous êtes si vous voulez encore
croire à la vie sociale des aloses or en
vous basant sur cette preuve là vous
imaginez qu'ils les aloses or il se
baladait par paquets d'au moins 44
c'est lourd ça fait beaucoup
d'allosaures 1 quand vous voyez la
taille du bestiau je sais pas ce qu'il
vous faut pour je ne sais pas ce que
vous chasser avec 44 allosaure mais à
part un tank
je vois pas il n'y a pas grand chose à
manger sur un tank
même cas pour dry alain job island où la
cdu tyrannosauridés qu'on a retrouvée
alors à la base c'est curie donc curie
je vous ai dit valeur sûre qui en 98
avait retrouvé neuf individus
neuf individus c'est un gros groupe
familial donc à l'époque il avait
proposé
justement la chasse ce qu'il avait dit
donc en 98 ce qu'il avait dit c'est que
en gros les petits dés les juvéniles
plus agile et plus rapide guidait les
adultes guidait les proies vers les
adultes les tyrannosauridés adultes qui
étaient plus puissants qui ont des
mâchoires plus puissante donc pareil
quand vous voyez ça dans une
reconstitution sur un reportage bbc one
ever ce que vous voyez c'est l'idée de
curry de 1998 mise en images à partir
des preuves qu'il avait à l'époque à
savoir neuf individus de tyrannosauridés
fossilisés en même temps au même endroit
sauf que depuis des fouilles ont été
refaites par ericsson et son équipe et
qu' ils ont déterré maintenant 22
individus
donc c'est pareil là 22 individus c'est
plus un gros groupe familial 22
individus ça commence à devenir plus une
rave party là non et qu'est ce qui est
encore une fois qu'est ce que vous
chasser avec 22 individus
combien combien il vous faut de
sauropodes enfin combien il vous faut de
sauropodes pour justifier de vous y
mettre à 22 tyrannosaure sachant qu'en
plus des sauropodes y en avait partout à
l'époque je suis pas sûr qu'on en ait
retrouvé d'un de typiquement à cet
endroit là je suis pas sûr qu'on ait
retrouvé de sauropodes médias à l'époque
en amérique du nord il ya que à la
mosson russe et je crois pas qu'on croit
qu'on leur trouve que
au mexique et au nouveau mexique mais
bref
quoi qu'il en soit de toute façon même 1
à la mosson russe ça justifie pas de
mobiliser de 22 tyrannosaure
donc non voilà maintenant on a quand
même suffisamment de restes de
tyrannosaure pour montrer pour dire que
non c'était franchement pas ça n'a pas
l'air d'aller dans le sens d'une d'un
petit groupe de familiale c'était un
gros groupe qui a probablement été
rassemblées par un processus géologiques
encore inconnues ou un piège à
prédateurs d'ailleurs la formation tout
médecine ou là on a retrouvé des das
plateau ruth trois individus entouré de
5 à droz or donc encore une fois si on
efface un cadre aux ors et 3 d'asp les
dozos remords à qui a profité le crime
puisqu'ils sont morts voilà encore une
fois interprétation de thanatos enos si
vous voulez dire qu'il chasser en meute
parce qu'il y en a trois qui sont morts
combien il était dans la meute en fait
est-ce qu'à chaque fois qu'ils chassent
d'ead rosoor il ya trois morts et dans
ce cas là ça veut dire que c'était
globalement extrêmement inefficace de
chasser en meute
voilà c'est pas c'est pas le sait c'est
embêtant comme interprétation une fois
de plus hélas qui se retrouvaient donc
ils disent des dizaines de dans d'autres
tyrannosauridés ont été retrouvés sur le
même site donc des dents isolées qui ont
certainement été cassé par la
consommation des cadavres et qui montre
que on est encore une fois peut-être
face à un un piège à prédateurs des des
cadavres qui s'accumulaient qui était
consommée par d'autres dinosaures
sauf que là ce piège à prédateurs l'aï
là il n'a pas accumulé que des
prédateurs d'une et surtout il a il ya
des prédateurs qui s'en sont sortis
puisqu'ils m'y ont laissé que des dents
donc voilà c'est et c'est pour ça que
c'est super intéressant en fait de
remonter à toutes ces idées de remonter
à l'origine de toutes ces idées c'est
c'est de voir justement que tout ce que
vous voyez dans les reportages ça vient
souvent de juste une petite phrase dans
un article voilà basé sur des preuves
tout au plus circonstancielle et pour et
avec tout ça on vous fait un énorme
scénario dans un
piment terre avec des images en 3d des
machins et tous qui vous font croire
qu'on sait tous exactement tout de ces
dinosaures et de la façon dont ils
chassaient alors qu'en fait banon c'est
juste une hypothèse qui avait été jeté
en l'air comme ça parce que bon a priori
c'est pas complètement incohérent avec
le fossile que j'ai bon par contre par
contre ça n'exclut pas tous les autres
scénarios
le fossile qui l'on n'exclut pas tous
les autres scénarios et il reparle
encore une fois des empreintes parallèle
et il montre là un assemblage dans
prennent parallèle mais qui est qu'ils
appartiennent encore une fois à plat
d'espèces différentes
parce que et il dit qu'en fait
généralement les les enfin il arrive
très souvent que les empreintes
finissent par être parallèle tout
simplement parce qu'il y avait qu'une
seule direction dans laquelle bouger
c'est par exemple le cas de des
prédateurs qui longe le littoral exemple
ça résultat plein d'empreintes parallèle
mais il n'y a pas forcément de raison
enfin il n'y a pas de raisons immédiates
pour laquelle ces empreintes sont
parallèles c'est une raison c'est une
raison indirects ce qui nous amène
finalement à notre dernier article celui
que j'avais traité pour le paléo news
donc ça nous amène à cet article donc
qui qui finalement apporté la première
preuve qu'il n'y avait pas de chasse en
groupe
chez les raptor donc jusque là je vous
ai montré que l'épreuve de chasse en
groupe chez les raptors
elle n'était pas forte du tout voire
même plutôt faiblarde est loin d'être
incontestable
maintenant voilà la preuve qu'il ne
chassait pas en groupe
bon sachant que je vous ai montré quand
même le velociraptor tout à l'heure qui
comme je les dis enfoncé le clou mais la
laci là on enfonce le deuxième clou dans
le cercueil de la théorie des raptors
qui chassent en meute
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont dans pour cet
article les chercheurs dont qui inclut
des grands noms enfin frederickson
je connais pas angels je connais pas
mais si félix est un grande c'est un
grand nom de la paléontologie américaine
dans american donc on peut lui faire
confiance
paléo 3 c'est un bon journal donc on
peut lui faire confiance et après le
format le format fait brouillon parce
que c'est effectivement il ne prouve
donc l'article a été acceptée il va être
publié mais il sera pas publique qui
était lequel ils vont refaire la mise en
page donc là c'est l'as rome c'est la
mise en page kaka voilà c'est pas la
jolie mise en page mais bref ce qu'ils
ont fait dans cet article donc c'est
qu'ils ont regardé la chimie des dents
est ce qu'il ya d'important à savoir
avec la chimie des danses et qu'elle se
forme quand l'animal grandi en fonction
de ce qu'il manque notamment la le
contenu en carbone si on regardait le
contenu en oxygène ce serait en fonction
de ce qu'il boit mais le contenu en
carbone des dents et notamment en
isotopes 13 du carbone
il dépend de ce qu'ils mangent et donc
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'en regardant
cette chimie de la danse si cette chimie
de la dent et plus riche et enrichie en
carbone 13 ça veut dire que l'animal se
nourrissaient d'autres carnivores
donc ça peut forcément besoin d'être des
t-rex ça peut être juste des araignées
des petits lézards des mammifères
insectivores enfin si vous savez des
trucs qui mangent des petits de la
petite protéine animale
voilà carnivores ça englobe way des
insectivores aussi c'est de la protéine
animale
donc si vous avez un enrichissement en
carbone 13 ça veut dire que vous vous ça
veut dire que vous vous nourrissez vous
même danier d'autres organismes qui se
nourrissait aussi de protéines animales
et donc le carbone 13 s'accumulent dans
la chaîne alimentaire
par contre si vous avez un taux de
carbone 13 bat ça veut dire que vous
consommez que vous consommez directement
à la source du carbone 13 c'est à dire
soit que vous et herbivores soit que
vous mangez des arts bilan c'est une
chose qu'on peut interpréter en termes
de biocénose assez de façon assez
justifiable parce que ça vient de la
chimie des dents qui et les danses forme
qui se fixe pendant la formation de la
dent et les danseux formes du vivant de
l'animal donc ya pas trop de doutes sur
le fait qu'on a un reflet direct d'une
biocénose et voilà pourquoi cet article
les prix beaucoup plus au sérieux que
tout ce qui a été fait auparavant que 70
ans de doctrine de raptor qui se
chassent en meute c'est parce que là on
a le nez directement sur la biologie de
l'animal et pas sur la façon dont il est
mort on est on regarde pas une cenne de
mort quand on regarde les isotopes on
regarde la géochimie de la vie de
l'animal est donc là on a regardé des
nordiques us donc bon on va partir du
principe qu'ils étaient pas herbivores
donc ils ont regardé des nonick us ils
ont des dents de juvéniles ils ont des
dents d'adulte et ils se sont rendus
compte qu'en moyenne des dents de
juvéniles avait une chimie différente de
celle des dents d'adulte et ils ont fait
ça dans deux formations la formation en
couleurs de la formation cloverleaf donc
à deux endroits différents afin
d'exclure en fait que ce soit la
géologie qui soit responsable de ces
différences géochimiques donc les deux
donnent le même signal à savoir que les
juvéniles ont une ondée dans plus
enrichie en carbone 13 que les adultes
ce qui veut dire que les juvéniles se
nourrissait plus haut dans la chaîne
alimentaire probablement de petits
lézards d'araignée 2 et 2 et de petits
mammifères insectivores pour ce qui
avait incité à cette époque on est au
crétacé il y en avait des mammifères
insectivores donc voilà c'est ça qui
nourrissait et c'est très en accord avec
ce qu'on a vu plus haut à on a vu ça
chez chez microraptor microraptor qui
s'en prenaient à des ennemis encore need
des mammifères et du poisson et donc
c'était pas tous des cons sommer des
consommateurs n'étaient pas tous des
herbivores ces bêtes là donc c'est assez
en accord avec les contenus stomacaux
est par contre on a les adultes qui se
nourrissait directement d'herbivores ce
qui est plutôt en accord avec ce conte
on a vu sur ténontosaure us donc des
carnivores enfin des adultes qui
pouvaient consommer de gros herbivores
comme ténontosaure us comme comme les
grands ptérosaures qu'on a vus comme
proto ceratops bref ça va en accord avec
une consommation d'herbe yvan st pas
forcément besoin d'être des gros
herbivores d'ailleurs ça peut être des
petits des arts vivants de taille
moyenne comme proto ceratops par exemple
et donc ce que ça veut dire c'est que
les petits va fallait qu'ils se
démerdent parce que si tu es nonick us
avaient chasser en meute et ballet petit
en fait ce qui se passe généralement ce
qui se passe au moment du repas chez les
espèces qui chassent en meute c'est que
la stratification sociale se met en
place vous avez d'abord les dominants
qui viennent manger les adultes dominant
qui ment qui mangent puis les adultes
dominé qui mangent puis seulement les
juvéniles qui se contentent des restes
de toute façon ils ont moins besoin ils
ont ils ont moins besoin de manger ils
sont plus petits donc
donc c'est dans cet ordre là que ça se
passe mais tout le monde mange sur la
même carcasse parce qu'il ya sinon ça
sert à rien de chasser en meute saharien
de chasser en meute si les petits
doivent aller manger ailleurs on est
bien d'accord que le seul intérêt de
prendre le risque de chasser à l'animal
plus gros que soi parce que ça c'est un
risque énorme de chasse est un animal
plus gros que soi donc prendre le risque
de s'y mettre à plusieurs pour chasser
un animal plus gros que soi c'est ça n'a
d'intérêt que si ça a un avantage
et si on en fait pas profiter tout le
monde
bâle avantage il est perdu donc voilà
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
faire l'hypothèse de la chasse en meute
c'est faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'hypothèses et notamment celle du soin
parentale et du tissu social et ça et
cette étude la montre que si soins
parental
il y avait ils allaient pas jusqu au
nourrissage déjà et ça montre que du
coup les petits ne se nourrissait pas au
même endroit au même source que les
adultes et que donc les adultes
globalement ne devait pas chassé pour
eux elle chasse et enfin ne devait pas
chassés pour leur juvénile et du coup il
est très peu probable qu'il chassait
pour qui que ce soit d'autre
voilà ils vont aussi déjà ils chassent
pas pour la progéniture pourquoi vous
voulez aller chasser pour le voisin d'à
côté quoi donc voilà cet article prouve
définitivement qu'il n'y avait pas le
tissu social nécessaire chez les raptors
pour soutenir une chasse en meute fin
fin de la discussion
et je du coup j'espère que cet article
rencontrera le succès qu'il est supposé
rencontre et j'espère que maintenant on
va voir des documentaires qui mettront
ça en images qui vont nous apprendre
qu'il y à controverse autour de la
chasse en meute parce que c'est comme
mon comme le disait l'article de roach
et brickman en 2007 et qualifié sa d'une
doctrine c'est parce que on en est venu
à un tel point que plus personne ne le
remet en question et que quand on ne
remet en question ben je dis moi je sais
pas s'ils vont se prendre une volée de
bois vert mais parce que l'article est
pas encore sorti officiellement mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que il va y avoir du
scepticisme dans l'air et
particulièrement du grand public puisque
c'est le grand public qui a été bercée
finalement avec avec jurassic park et
tous ces documentaires c'est pas
tellement c'est pas tellement au niveau
des chercheurs mais c'est effectivement
au niveau du grand public qu'on risque
d'avoir du scepticisme donc j'espère que
les paléo artistes vont accepter l'idée
et vont se mettre à nous représenter des
baux velociraptor aider bodrum et aux
heures d beaudignies cus en train de
chasser tout seul voilà je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette longue vidéo et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
ciao